after two years of negotiations we have
achieved a detailed arrangement that
permanently prohibits Iran from
obtaining a nuclear weapon it does not
resolve all problems certainly doesn't
resolve all our problems with Iran it
does not ensure a warming between our
two countries under this deal Iran
cannot acquire the plutonium needed for
a bomb Iran has powerful incentives to
keep its commitments if we're on
violates the agreement over the next
decade all of the sanctions can snap
back into place nuclear material isn't
something you hide in the closet it can
leave a trace for years the bottom line
is if Iran cheats we can catch them and
we will you are going to hear a lot of
arguments against this deal backed by
tens of millions of dollars in
advertising and if the rhetoric in these
ads and the accompanying commentary
sounds familiar it should for many of
the same people who argued for the war
in Iraq for now making the case against
the Iran nuclear deal ironically the
single greatest beneficiary in the
region of that war was the Islamic
Republic of Iran by killing this deal
Congress would not merely pave Iran's
pathway to a bomb it would accelerate it
those who say we can just walk away from
this deal and maintain sanctions are
selling a fantasy instead of
strengthening our position as some have
suggested Congress's rejection would
almost certainly result in multilateral
sanctions unraveling their opponents of
this deal who accept the choice of war
in fact they argue that surgical strikes
against Iran's facilities will be quick
and painless
but if we've learned anything from the
last decade it's that wars in general
and wars in the Middle East in
particular are anything but simple
Israel can defend itself against any
conventional danger whether from Iran
directly or from its proxies on the
other hand a nuclear-armed Iran changes
that equation there are times when force
is necessary and if Iran does not abide
by this deal it's possible that we don't
have an alternative but how can we in
good conscience justify war before we've
tested a diplomatic agreement that
achieves our objectives so this deal is
not just the best choice among
alternatives this is the strongest
non-proliferation agreement ever
negotiate